these three scientists against a single
parasite adrian nayer had the idea hans
peterbeck and wolfgang meyer are
supervising his project their research
is still in its early phases but they
hope one day to successfully fight
malaria
why malaria because there still isn't
much broad-based research and industry
doesn't have a vested interest in it so
i feel that the university lab is a good
place to test things out
the world
talk to me about it and it sounded very
clever
i thought we could and should pursue it
we hope it will work but we're not 100
sure that it will
part of the research is being done at
the swiss tropical and public health
institute in basel
the scientists are focusing on the
malaria vectors and parasites
the mosquito lab is bathed in warm light
and the humidity is literally tropical
hans peterbeck has been investigating
infected mosquitoes for
this type of mosquito carries plasmodium
phosphorus a common type of malaria
parasite that's responsible for most
malaria deaths worldwide the
single-celled organism looks like a blue
squiggle under the microscope in humans
it attacks its victims red blood cells
the urethra sites
the parasite has developed mechanisms
that allow it to adhere to the capillary
walls
if we can prevent this we could prevent
the symptoms of the disease
and if we could prevent the parasite
from invading erythrocytes we would
prevent it from proliferating
my plan was to try to use the kind of
nanostructures we work with to see if we
could apply nanotechnology and polymer
chemistry to find a solution
for the last four years adrian nayer's
research in the chemistry department at
basel university has been directed at
confusing the parasites
he does so first by creating mixtures of
polymers the ingredients he uses are
fairly simple but achieving the desired
result is highly complex he wants to
create vesicles artificial bubble like
structures that are so tiny they're
invisible to the naked eye
the idea is for the bubbles which he
calls nano mimics to resemble human
blood cells
this is supposed to trick the parasite
because it sees what looks like a normal
blood cell
it doesn't have a brain it doesn't think
i will invade this blood cell it simply
adheres to it
so theoretically it adheres to our
structure too
if the process is efficient then we can
block the parasite that was the basic
idea and we've achieved it
the parasites highlighted in green
aren't approaching the real blood cells
but the artificial vesicles
once inside they're unable to
proliferate and so they die off
crucially however the bubbles must not
measure more than two ten thousandths of
a millimeter
if the nano structures were too big and
you injected them into an organism they
wouldn't circulate in the blood
but in the case of malaria that's what
we need to happen
the vesicles form successfully but nano
expert wolfgang meyer knows there are
still many unanswered questions
if you want to use them as an active
substance then you need to know how
stable they are how long can they be
stored
and if you inject them or use them as
medication
how long will it take for them to
decompose
once the laboratory research is finished
the scientists will start running tests
on mice and humans
even if it works perfectly it will be
years before it goes to market that's
just the way it is we hope we can get
results that are constructive and that's
a time-consuming process you need to be
committed to
with ingenuity and persistence the basel
scientists may have come up with a truly
new way of tackling malaria